We need guarantees
that these psychologists
who will come to psychological jobs to
schools will not be roundup people
it won't be like today
when curators agree massively
on a massive scale
for jobs of psychologists
Employing people without education
without yy qualifications
We need a law on the profession of psychologist
we need regulation of the profession of psychologist yes
Regardless of this
or an adult patient customer
Go to the psychological office.
When a child at school
You will want to use this help.
Each of these people must know
that he does not meet with a fairy
Not with an exorcist.
not with someone who did some postgraduate courses
Evening with Psychology
It actually goes to a specialist.